that's not the plan it's real 92 3 we
live at the BT Awards yeah and this
guy's got the hottest song in the
country right now come on [__] five
man say hi girl we live we are live well
no we're not live you can say whatever
the [__] you want respect [__] file
man she a hot girl come here baby's here
I gotta be honest with you talk to me
you got the only song yeah in the last
three years you don't listen to rap that
I like that's what's up I stopped
listening to new musics is like 2016
2017. word and you turn my my wife into
a stripper oh my God she heard the song
I said you gotta shake your ass we put a
pole in the living room now she's saying
something every other day
first of all how was your father's day
was it good it was beautiful man you
know that's my favorite thing to do
period Well you know I feel like
Father's Day really ain't about us
really as much as it's about like yo let
me take you somewhere I want to go what
you got some house shoes I got some
cologne bro some cologne or some [__]
was it a good kind yeah it was some
Jimmy
got a lot of hugs and kisses man that
was enough for me man you know I'm
talking about our spa day bro yeah
exactly yeah the size of pedicure or
something like that I just want to say
man you know I've been riding with you
for a long time and I'm just super happy
that you got through this weird cancel
Cloud you have officially defeated
cancel coaches not for sure
congratulations man we're gonna stay on
top of we belong yeah I mean um I know
you got a great relationship with boozy
speaking of guys who can't be canceled
have you spoke with him since he got out
I haven't I haven't I ain't had a chance
to speak with him yet I think he out
here though he's out here right now yeah
okay I'm gonna bump into him
um how's this album sounding that you're
working on man look we got another three
pack on the way right now we got to
shake something remix that [__]
might drop before you wake up in the
morning who's on it
female rapper yes
sexy red
I'ma tell you when when the music is
sexy right on the remix did I just guess
that
okay [__]
I'm like the way Arnold just reacted
[__] hey the five got weird when you
said oh yeah I think you got it right
you might have been a good pick we might
I might need to read
um all right listen Brandon Miller just
got drafted to your Hornets where's the
first place you're taking him to in
Charlotte where's he going to eat is it
the strip club what are we doing with
the rookie I ain't gonna lie I want to
scoop
I mean look
and you
I ain't gonna say nothing bad about the
Hornets yeah it does it inspired me to
yeah hey the Jordan curse is gone man
yeah that's what I'm saying man we need
to yeah Jake so yeah I I love the fact
that J Cole in that man cause hopefully
he come in moving some things around and
try some [__] up you know I'm saying
like we need dogs we need dogs you know
what I'm saying why I want to scoop we
need to screw the dog for sure I want
the [__] at the draft with the teeth
with the gold teeth in his mouth yeah
you don't want to been through something
yeah I want to yeah I want you know we
need that we need a dog the one that has
some life in them we need a dog he got
to make it yeah there it is but listen
baby I appreciate you brother I'm gonna
see you this week
appreciate you my God